podcast man shout out to LRG shout out
to Def Jam we and AZ for the Super Bowl
damn it daily finesse no phone daily
let's go
[Music]
Daddy
finesse no ashes dollar signs all that
add me up I mean
shut up with that kid
[Music]
yeah look Moon walking in these running
away Louise he's ain't join us if you
gotta check the price tag you probably
can't afford it Jack it costs a two-door
and I barely even what probably
somewhere in the ocean poor Lena like
it's water I may be in a Cuts counting
up just like a barber I look how far we
came but I know we can go further
Chandelier's Persian rugs in the
countertop saw a Marvel when I'm
starving call my chef I've got a key so
he just walk in and find this little
[__] in the East who I can get lost in
pull up in the jet skis in a Waters down
Laughlin smoking on a zob levitating
while I'm walking killing [__] on every
song like put that [__] in a coffin hit
a man around the city so these hoes
cannot get off them understand that's
what my plan is just happening when you
on Boss [__] so my [__] to get a tan
when my [__] split up the profit I
counted something like 90. remind me
you're done on dock it put 85 in the
safe other five in my pocket favorite
personal driver other one is a pilot I
tell my [__] go [__] a friend I'm not
gonna see you try no [__] that selling
stuff and they pushing it out that
higher try stopping [__] from winning
we [__] around start a riot hit the
dealer see that car if I like it and I'm
just
[__] the [__] you settling for the only
one of my impression don't you play with
that boy [__] streets love me they say
daily get a city hope two things never
felt never flying coach six words
getting money I just died broke show up
to dinner and Cartier is just to make a
toast okay some cameras flashing I guess
you never know someone's traffic on my
street they think I'm selling dope but
all my [__] talking codes guess they
never know a day I got a ball for like
I'm going pro I slick talk just like a
player dude I love to hustle pull up in
different business like it's painful
just always love me and they pay to see
me call it pay-per-view and Fashion
Square burning all the Louie ain't [__]
else to do [__] I'm getting money now
truly I mean it the best thing in AZ
like KD is the Phoenix it's daily [__]
hey what up y'all appreciate you guys
watching this week's freestyle we're
dropping another one next week and
sometimes we drop more than one in a
week but they're always brought to you
by LRG baby that's right loving me some
LRG always and right now if you go to
the website
l-r-g.com and you use the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get 30 off 30 off
that's almost half
at checkout that's right all right shout
out to LRG one more time L Dash R Dash
g.com and when you check out use that
promo code bootleg and save 30 off the
freestyles we'll be back next week
always brought to you by LRG baby